welcome to this video playing a tech GM
sir Julian auction he is so yes let's
avoid the Trump okay we got a whoops got
a French defense quite sure what he's
doing in the French Knight f6 okay maybe
I can get some rare line in there
sometimes play he is not a regular 1.e4
guy so I hope that he's actually not
knowing this too well okay who's Knight
f3 maybe I can play b6 now for Bishop a6
that cannot be too bad against a slow
setup like Jagger 30 credits already
quite comfortable for black this kind of
thing so may I can kick their butt I
have many many moves that I can play
before I take on d3 now that's a typical
maneuvering gaining some space on the
kingside I can go can I do that I wonder
decide to move intending pinon Bishop b3
interesting
what's a blocking I am so he doesn't how
does he tell does it take now aha so he
doesn't mind that but it's not a bad end
game at all here right that's a good end
game for black I get see hive in next so
see 5 or not that's an interesting
question actually I don't have to play
it right away I can try to block him
knight c6 is what I'm contemplating
interesting okay that's been fact
interesting c5 Emil he can go f5 but I
have okay let's do that until I'm taking
too long here actually
if I die once you go be 50 yes a six
maybe he would play a 6 that's
interesting try to isolate the b5 point
if he allows me to play out it takes huh
surprising if he allows me to play a 6
i'm just in very good shape that already
looks good actually d3 is hanging so it
doesn't manage to play six if i get to
get a six and i'm just clearly better
because he has weaknesses all over all
over the place do you 3c three
everything now it's nothing serious yet
but he's got weaknesses yeah I'm
entering the auto capture on c3 probably
he won't take but hmm what is he doing
if he's not taking I mean I have night
84 may be attacking c3 currently the
night on h2 is also looking rather inept
yeah some is taking a while then he
takes it just a moment I had to cancel
to my pre move yeah so I'm going to play
here and make sure that this is a good
structure let's see how to continue as
an interesting question hmm really
f I didn't expect that okay let's double
on the CFL some night f5 is going g4 so
that's not going to help so knight c6
intending maybe d4 before as interesting
and also looking at that a five pawn so
BRD for was my idea here see for though
but then i can take and take a five yeah
so that's just good right
Wow take a five what is this what's the
point does he have some breakthrough or
what ok interesting t5 and then f5 or
something yes to do something drastic
otherwise I'm just winning in night to
d5 and it's over yeah it has to be
something drastic Knight d4 f5 that
could be good beard interesting
yeah I know with choice i have to take
94 then g6 probably now that's also
interesting 41 for my five then f6 ok
now it's doing that immediately of
course and then takes a 68 kid only
could be something something tactical
stupid stupid stupid yeah that's a shame
yeah very nice yeah okay black resigns
as stupid and Justin cf6 I'm still okay
after King in seven but of course I was
just better in them in this game so
right here black is just better I think
but the engine does not agree so did I
did I screw it up earlier at some point
I really think that I'm I should be in
in good shape here where did I make some
mistake at some point
that's interesting nuts is six that sets
really far better interesting app now
you have to be precise maybe I should
have taken a moment down the point is
that now if five is really hanging a six
is a desirable move from me but this is
a better way to do it just better in a
taxi five that's very important he
cannot do that because of G for that
that's clearly in blacks favor so it has
to do Knight f3 probably and this means
that those pawns are far less dangerous
no way sick that's a far better version
of the gamma T I'm actually really
slightly better because he doesn't have
that that counter play there on there on
the kingside higher that was good then a
form the I am I I really thought I
should be should be a better him but it
doesn't seem to be the case well that's
cute the engine wants to do this maybe
yeah maybe this is this is a real
problem I was of course i was looking at
this and thought okay that's a coolant
game but the problem is that this is not
going to work because of f5 and then f6
and he's breaking through it's his
typical thing with the yeah the quad
grip pawn structure this pawn struck I
simply I didn't appreciate that that
means night XD for was even better and
that makes deform somewhat yeah makes it
a bad move I probably should this just
stay which makes it equal so I am most
not wrong in believing I am fine just
that I already had skipped an
opportunity at this particular we have
to go knight c6 yeah that's much better
interesting to prevent this F for more
yeah well did this really cannot cannot
be anything for white it's this kind of
this kind of setup gives black a very a
very decent position that looks that
looks completely okay I don't don't
really think as much to to improve him I
can maybe take the pawn it's not totally
totally crazy to do that but anyway b5
looks looks fine that's a good good
strategically consistent move yeah I
have to go knight c6 that's really it
just really amazing that sets clearly
clearly better than a six preventing is
a form yeah but okay I don't need to
lose obviously well d 4 is a mistake
because of 90s but the way it went am I
took here then he went to g5 I can also
this opportunity ever also interesting
no probably computer says equal not
maybe what about this then is that said
a big problem here can i still hold that
this is probably right and now this one
yeah it's just you particular g5 is just
in just neurotic move i have to go here
check and this is one one possible line
it looks a bit a bit questionable but
okay i'm a power nap so maybe those
pawns can observe those pawns can help
this
can I take here only not no I cannot do
that so i have to take here and probably
hear they're it's got that it looks
questionable for black the computer
gives 000 though and would that reduce
material it's probably calculating it
till the end now that all an interesting
game in any case okay well thanks for
watching